sur sa voix représentées plantu parce
qu'il n'a encore rien dit alors plantu
vous êtes très jeune vous êtes
journaliste au monde j'ai appris que
vous étiez vous avez été un élève de
monsieur ségur elle l'année dernière
justement comme je nage un peu dansé
dans ces milieux-là de deux spécialistes
en économie ou en politique ont toutes
sortes de choses et que moi j'essaye de
d'illustrer leurs papiers j'ai à force
de d'illustrer des papiers en économie
je me suis dit quand même que j'ai quand
même des pas mal de pas mal de choses à
rattraper et je me suis j'ai demandé au
journal de me faire bénéficier de cours
à sciences pour l'année dernière dans le
cadre de la formation permanente et vous
êtes j'eus écureuils ou alors vous êtes
le jacques faisant du monde
je suis pas comme vous voulez d éthique
et vous êtes le destine à commande y est
aussi jeune dessinateur du monde ils
placeraient rechercher sa ba quand je me
suis présenté il ya 11 ans apparemment
ce n'était pas tellement cherché à voir
elle je pense pas beaucoup de jeu je me
suis présentée j'ai présenté mes dessins
et puis petit à petit vous avez intégré
comment ça se passe le matin comme vous
apporter un ou plusieurs dessins voit ce
que la direction choisie comme comment
ça se passe
le matin rapporte souvent à dessein vers
9h20 9h 10h sur le sujet que j'ai décidé
parce que je me rêvais c'est aux gens
regardent la télé la veille jeudi les
journaux du matin
et puis
et j'écoute la radio et je à partir de
toutes les informations que
que j'ai entendu ou lu jeu
je fais mon choix je déjà détermine le
sujet qui m'a le plus intéressé le plus
mal fait réagir qui m'a fait le plus
réagir et je présente ou un brouillon
parce que je le termine toujours un peu
en retard et je termine au journal après
avoir montré brouillon rédacteur en chef
après celle acquise ici et là-bas en
général ils le pren mais je préfère
avoir un petit peu la température du
journal et puis de celui qui s'occupe de
la partie que j'ai décidé d'illustrer
pour pour terminer mon dessin comme ça
je sens bien être à l'heure au sens que
votre directeur vous aime beaucoup andré
laurens puisqu'il il a fait une préface
à votre ouvrage alors ils disent aussi
plantu pose un regard clair et sans
méchanceté sur l'actualité quand vous
voir en se dit que c'est bien vrai et il
la voit les l'actualité lequel est avec
ses misères ses contradictions ses
absurdités
il réagit plus qu'il ne juge et c'est
avec la même innocence qu'il épingle
tous les acteurs de la scène politique
jeudi le mot innocent ce moment un peu
surpris parce que je pense pas quand
même qu'on puisse être un dessinateur
humoriste humoristes en étant innocent
je crois pas aux olives je crois que au
bout d'un certain temps en ayant regardé
la qualité en lisant beaucoup évidemment
on a quand même un recul on finit par
avoir des ddd réaction
des choix et
et puis ce sont ses choix que j'essaie
d'exprimer sous forme de dessin alors
par le choix le choix par exemple il ya
un dessin va montrer quelques-uns page
alors ça c'est je voterai à titre
personnel pour monsieur giscard
d'estaing ça c'est jacques chirac
on le voit donc j'espère qu'on va vous
le montrer en soit c'est un dessin très
très cruel que vous avez fait au moment
de la campagne électorale présidentielle
on voit donc jusqu'à chirac se boucher
le nez et met son dans l'urne le
bulletin pour giscard et vous le trouvez
ce méchant ah non mais non pas du tout
non je pense que vous êtes très riche en
monuments fais dire qu'il est comme
jouer mais change we will et holly
chambre à louer tradition avec une
gentillesse dans dessins et sinon héros
cité dans l'esprit du dessin et
n'inquiétait beaucoup c'est le titre on
va j'ai cru que c'était un petit coup de
matraque à ton goût la navette à lembeye
venir la guillotine
alors y en a un autre que j'aime
beaucoup c'est peut-être mon préféré y
les pages 22 donc la page derrière alors
ça c'est le lendemain des élections
c'est mitterand qui a gagné comme chacun
sait est alors ça alors le président est
socialiste et la tour eiffel est
toujours à sa place
incroyable ouais justement ça refléter
un peu ce que disaient les les léotard
dont vous parlez dans votre livre qu'ils
disaient j'avais toujours où mitterrand
sera au pouvoir vous verrez il y aura
des queues devant les magasins sont en
afrique
et puis j'ai mal à la france et la chine
au bond et puis le dessin de couverture
c'est le goulag un sas et c'était
d'abord ce que j'entendais dire beaucoup
surtout du côté de la droite parce que
je me suis rendu compte que vraiment les
gens étaient effrayés que justement on
vous en parlait dans votre livre la
manière dont les capitaux ont fichu le
camp ensuite ça a été ça a été assez
époustouflant oui mais bon ben je
voulais exprimer
alors évidemment ce sont les goulags et
guy par des gens qui n'ont rien à